i was playing the u.s championship in
2000
uh i think this was 14. on the rest day
of the us championship which is a day in
which no games were played it allows the
players to catch their breath usually in
the middle of the tournament
there's usually some sort of
get-together that's hosted uh by
one of the organizers just to let the
players chill a little bit and and in st
louis next to the chess center which i'm
sure some of you have been there
there is a a big house that's owned by
rex and
that house is used to host sometimes the
commentators you know some people
dignitaries who come to st
louis it's a big big you know stately
house
uh and the sort of rest day party was
held there and yasser was there playing
blitz with maurice ashley
um and you know some of the players were
there fabi was there
you know it's it's fun you know it's
intense but it's fun we're all competing
but
we're all trying to be friendly uh and
you know some drinks are served and it's
very important during a tournament to be
as healthy as you can possibly be you
know no shenanigans
uh but i allowed myself a a drink uh on
the rest day which is
rare but you know just one but yasser
who is you know
i know that he's rooting for me and he
always has been
he's coming around 15 bucks from the
crazy fool and he looks at me holding a
cup and he's like
and you know yasser is so chill he gets
super intense
he's like that's that's not alcohol is
it and and he's like dead serious and i
get
i get like so red and i'm like no that's
just sprite
uh but but it was just funny that you
know yasser is very chill but i know
he's he can be intense too and i mean
that in a very good way
okay let's get started uh let me get my
notebook ready
so i can take notes and uh answer
questions properly
or should i shall i say properly let's
go e4
knight f3 okay but okay maybe some
italian
some some italian chess very good but
okay
we can play fried liver okay but i think
we will play simple chess g3 okay
supports up one castle here very nice
but okay this is boring chess but it is
very effective to illustrate the
principles of chess we go c3 now to
prepare d4 this is typical theory
but okay i see ukraine
this is a typically named inaudible okay
so this is uh let's get serious
uh i'm supposed to be instructive people
say i'm i can be a good teacher so i so
i gotta i gotta hold that reputation
uh okay so this is the mainline italian
uh the mainline italian has become
incredibly popular recently i only
played it once
in my life since i became a gm i played
it to beat my only super gm
yakivenko so i have a good experience
with it
i don't have a great handle on white's
main ideas but
what are the essentials of of this setup
right why am i doing what i'm doing
the pawn on c3 is as you guys know
helping to prepare d4
i can't play d4 yet and what i'm going
to do in this position
is i'm going to orchestrate a very
typical maneuver you guys who play the
ray lopez i'm sure you know this
this knight from d2 is going to go to g3
what is the purpose of that the purpose
of that
is that the knight will have access to
this incredibly strong square on
f5 uh it doesn't mean i'm going to go
there immediately because there's a
bishop on c8
but i'm going to threaten that and he
goes knight r4 now the second idea of
the italian
comes into play do you remember i played
c3 i just talked about this
how do i defend against this threat in
the most efficient manner what do i do
uh and and this shows you how flexible
and how resilient of an opening the
italian is we go t4 we intercept the
bishop and we do it with tempo
this move is useless we can actually
play h3 and do something productive for
our position
and chase the knight away he gives us
the whole center not a good idea he
probably wants to go here he's attracted
by this move at tempo
but i've already talked no he's not okay
so bishop a7
uh and okay this is annoying the hell
out of me so let's get it out of there
and uh let's complete our maneuver that
we started with knight g3 don't forget
to do that
okay goes he's playing already well i
mean our opponents are already playing
pretty well
uh and these wins are not going to be
that easy so how do we continue our
development
such that we do not obstruct any of our
pawns and any of our control over pawns
so where where should we put this guy um
e3 d2 what do you guys think
we can actually put it on e3 and and
this is a typical
idea in the italian uh it relies on
tactics but in this game just to keep
the simplicity i'm gonna go bishop f4
which is not my favorite move
but it's fine uh and i will explain why
bishop e3
is generally the way that this is played
because e4 is actually untouchable
okay um we haven't really completed okay
well bishop b7 first of all notice that
he's relinquishing his control over f5
not only that but what he's doing and
this people might not see
right this king is actually really
really weak it's not really surrounded
by any of his pieces you guys can see
that all of his pieces are kind of
clustered on the queen side
and we can prepare a very typical
sacrificial idea
to blast open uh the king inside now you
guys might be seeing bishop takes h6 but
can this move be prepared can we prepare
to take on h6 so that it comes with a
lot greater effect
and if so how and again this is this
idea is entirely within the range of
typical
now a lot of you want to go knight to
five but i'm greedy i don't want to give
this e4 pawn
i don't want to give away the c4 pawn i
want to i want to prepare it in another
way and i'm going to go queen d2
uh and knight f5 would be fine actually
we can give the spawn up anyway and take
on h6 and i'm sure that's good
but i wanna i wanna avoid any kind of
complication
not only that but notice that when i
take on h6 i'm gonna have a queen that
lands on h6
i said many times that you need to
employ the queen only for the most
sort of big balls tasks this is a pretty
big boss task i mean you're trying to
check me the king
i'd say this is good enough to involve
the queen wouldn't you
the knights are performing right now a
defensive role
that's great they are supporting the
central pawns but they might just as
well when the king side opens perform an
attacking role
when i climb a little bit in raiding
i'll talk about kinetic and potential
energy i think i talked about it already
in previous streams but i'll talk about
it again in the context of the stream as
we take on h6 as flind
uh and and taken h6 he's completely
busted here look at his king it's it's
wide open
now knight f5 is going to be incredibly
strong because he has no defense to
checkmate he has to give away his queen
in the game and look how quickly we
didn't even do any attacking
as my coach would say prepare slowly
attack fast this is what that means
right you do all the necessary
preparations
so that you don't have to go crazy when
you're attacking you can just
make easy moves and by the way i had an
even better way to prepare queen g7 what
would it have been
it wouldn't have even allowed him to
give up a queen
while the pawn has pinned the f-pawn has
been what would
what would it have been
no no he didn't say anything
i
knight h5 yeah knight h5 would have been
even more precise it doesn't matter i'm
completely winning because we are up a
queen and we're mating him
i think that's good enough thank you
eric uh
i think that's good enough intro light
thank you for the prime let's go knight
g5 he's pinned and we're gonna prove him
pre-move checkmate uh this is pretty
straightforward attacking uh okay mate
i'm not gonna go over this with a fine
toothed comb
um at this point this is just standard
attacking practices
this was actually a really good game um
and it's a very instructive one in terms
of illustrating some of the main ideas
of the italian
which i'm going to do after the game in
the meantime let's continue playing
uh and i will do some sub sub events on
my main account so i knew i'll play you
and uh let's continue with e4 let's do
another italian i think well okay
i don't know guys why it is that the
philidor is so popular at this level i
wasn't aware of that
uh and i don't particularly like it okay
so he's playing like the duke of
brunswick against morphe and perhaps the
most famous game of all time
does anybody know how white should
respond to this move
this is this is following the famous
opera game which probably over 50
percent of you know
it's also one of the most overrated
games of all time now the idea of bishop
g4 is to pin the knight the problem is
he has to take the knight in order to be
able to recapture the pawn this is
exactly how the morphe game went
what did morphy play here uh and it's a
very natural move
i bet morphy made here in order to
develop a tempo he plays bishop c4
are we doing this to threaten scholars
mate no this is
this is not how it went right the guy
playing duke of brunswick played knight
f6 and then morphy played queen b3 i
think
uh we could play queen b3 anyway but
then he's going to go queen before check
and he's going to force the queen trait
so let's just focus on developing
i am angry i can't recreate it so let's
keep developing
okay let's just keep developing we are
still overwhelmingly better we have the
two bishops
uh his queen is obstructing the
development of his bishop i mean he's in
very bad shape here and we're just going
to keep developing
he continues to push his pawns out i
don't know why he's not concerned about
this
all right so how should we accumulate
the pressure we've done some of the key
development moves what else can we do
for our position here to take care of
our pieces uh and remember
we don't always have to develop all the
pieces in sequence donald
trump i i agree with that approach rook
b4 b5 would be very
very creative idea i like that but let's
let's play more stereotypically let's
get the rook to an open file
uh to restrict his king even further oh
man he's asking for it isn't he
queen f6 do we trade queens obviously
not where should we slide our queen to
think about the pathways to the king
where should we put our queen uh this
would be
tempting but it doesn't actually
threaten anything right because both of
these squares are covered
can we try to threaten a square that's
not currently covered
i see some of you saying h3 and that's
exactly right or jeff i would play queen
g4
the reason why is because we're not
making the tempting move that looks the
nicest
we're trying to actually get the queen
over to c8 this square is uncovered
the other thing we're trying to do is oh
oh man oh my lands this was
not the greatest yeah okay mate okay he
just resigned okay he thought i'm
rubbing it in his face by not moving but
i'm just trying to involve everybody in
the process
and and before i go to the next game i
just wanted to
to to clarify a couple of things here
why did i not play queen d3 so first of
all
i wrote a chess.com article a while ago
called queen the supporting actress
and i had the privilege of training with
yasser sarawan a couple of years ago in
st louis i did a three-day training
session with him and he actually
revolutionized my perspective on
some of these things including the role
of the queen
and yasser yes daniel so
first of all yes so what yasser said
is is that very often
this reminds me first of all of a story
so okay but
seriously because i want to keep things
going smoothly and this will not be a
long stream
yasser said that the queen we often
think of it as the main attacker the
queen is the main attacker it's the main
the big balls character
not always true the queen is sometimes
best in a supporting role
and i made this analogy to napoleon
stuck in russia
consider the queen to be your main
general right queen is remain war
general
are you going to send out your main war
general into the battle of sumter or
whatever first battle you're fighting
um is it going to be doing the frontline
fighting
or is it going to be in the shadows
directing the conflict it's not a great
analogy because the chest is not war
and blah blah blah but you get the point
the queen is often best in the shadows
because it has
long-range capabilities it doesn't need
to be in your opponent's face
we've talked about this theory that's
why very often we want to play moves
like queen d3 we wanna we want the queen
to be first you know we want the queen
to aim at the king
it's not always how the queen works best
by putting it on h3 we're putting it on
a safe place where it's shaded by
by some of the pieces and pawns and in
addition the queen is a lot more
effective
here aiming for c8 and d7 then it would
be on d3 where it's aiming for d8 which
is covered quite well by our opponents
uh i don't want to belabor the point
here i think people get it but just
wanted to kind of
emphasize that that's the case you can
search up my article if you want more
about this called queen the supporting
actress that's how yasser called it
one more game and then we're going to
autopsy the last three mate
71 from slovenia i think okay let's play
the sicilian again
we played this italian once yesterday
i'm gonna play it again and he plays
bishop c4
now listen up and i'll talk more about
tournaments and everything later i
promise
this is very commonly played by
beginners against the sicilian it is a
literal transposition of the italian
against this italian the problem is it
doesn't work the same way
and there is a very simple reason why
the reason why bishop c4 is not as
effective
in the sicilian as in the italian
usually why is it
exactly you can play e6 you can blot the
bishop and furthermore
you can play d5 and occupy the center
with tempo okay
now i have the center get out of here
and look at this bishop just staring at
my well-defended pawn that's not the way
you want it to be
now we can just develop our pieces
normally and we've got a great position
i'm playing quickly here
this position how do we continue
developing and we do so
the same way that we would in any
opening you don't need to think of the
situation as speaking another language i
mean
we just develop our pieces actively in
the same exact way we could have also
played h6 by the way to stop his bishop
from coming out to g5 but the reality is
this bishop's development is a lot
he's asking for it again what should we
do what would i do here
you guys have seen enough of my my
psychopath games
to know what the heck it is i would i'm
sacking the knight here i'm not gonna
let him get away with this stuff okay
probably unsound
and that's the reality of it probably
unsound but look at his king
look at the pin and uh we need to be
very careful here for black we don't
just want to willy-nilly throw our
pieces at the king
that's not how you attack uh the move
knight t4 believe it or not he can
actually take on d5 and simultaneously
defend the knight
so we got to be very careful here let's
do this anyway because it's the point is
not
to win his knight the point is to
orchestrate this tension on his knight
that can be then
used as currency okay well he doesn't
see it
for the record bishop takes d5 uh would
have defended his knight i'll explain
how i would have proceeded then
he goes king g2 which is a big mistake
what should we do
in order to transform our attack into a
material advantage
very simple move um
bishop takes knight it's a fork against
the queen the knight defends the bishop
and let's take stock we have a queen for
two pieces and we have a couple of pawns
on top of it
we're probably not gonna be able to
defend this pawn but that's fine let's
try to remove the last remaining
defender on his king right his king is
somewhat protected by his bishop
what can people suggest to do and i know
some people probably are thinking d4 but
remember my key piece of advice here
when you're up this much material your
top priority is not to defend every
single pawn which is not to say you
should be giving them away willy-nilly
but honestly that should be very low on
your list of priorities okay what should
we do now now that we've removed the
bishop from f4 the bishop has been
replaced with a knight
knight's far worse defender and we can
actually bring our queen we can pin the
knight attack the pawn
and obviously we can play g5 and just
snap this knight off and the game is
over
all right a very simple attack uh and
now
some of the key rules of attack are
displayed
by which i mean we we should bring all
of our attacking pieces and we shouldn't
try to rely only on the queen
and ever i mean i really like the fact
that everybody's just finding moves here
so
this is awesome you guys are i know that
some of you are
paying attention actively and
concentrating and i really appreciate
that
it's an honor uh to have to have people
like that and and i know
everybody's busy so thank you i i this
means a lot to me people are really
actively engaged and that's awesome okay
uh regarding the discord yeah i've been
really slacking
but as you guys know i've been really
pushing the content production
production recently this this takes time
for me to prepare
uh and i'll try my best to keep that up
as i stabilize
okay uh well thank you note again the
honor is all mine and i appreciate it
truly
but i'll talk about that later let's do
the autopsy on the games and then we're
going to continue
now this first game we played the main
line italian most people
play the fried liver for the record the
fried liver
does not win it is not it is a good
opening i mean gm's play it
but what should black do in this
position in the fried liver uh for those
of you who play one e5 with black do not
take the knight
the pawn on d5 you already know this you
should play knight a5
uh and this leads to some you know very
interesting complications black
sacrifices upon
if you want more about this i did a
session with nicola which will continue
as well where we talked about this at
length
black is compensation for the pawn in
what form well black is an initiative
right black is attacking all of white's
pieces he's pushing his funds
we're not going to delve into the
opening intricacies here just suffice it
to say the position is about equal
by modern theory uh opinion and uh it's
an interesting line
uh but the mainline italian is uh has
had a resurgence recently obviously it's
been around since basically the 1600s
uh but but but it's a very uh it's a
very rich opening and
it's it's an opening that i'm kind of
sick of seeing at the high level because
the game's in a draw very often
it's similar to the rye lopez in several
different ways how would i describe a
position like this what would you
what would you pay attention to there's
a couple of things to notice here blacks
both sides are very solid
um both sides let me check discord
aquila ooh
tequila in russian wow nice that does
look very nice
so both sides are you know very solid
here very solid structurally white
is supposed to have maybe a little bit a
little bit of something because of this
idea of going d4
i'm not gonna delve into the details of
this
uh i will say what is the best for e4
players right lopez every time i
personally have played the rye lopez
a lot longer than i played the italian i
used to play the attack well actually i
never played the italian i played the
scotch
so when i was 14 1500 and when i come
home in a week
i will i and i forgot to do this the
last time but i will get
out some of my old score sheets and i'll
show you guys
some of my oldest score sheets from 2003
2004. i've kept all of them
uh and i used to play the scotch and
after the scotch i played the rye lopez
which is
a different kind of opening than the
italian right it's similar in some ways
and it's different in others it's just
it leads to different types of positions
uh and
and it's hard for me to summarize in one
or two sentences what the differences
are contained but there are similarities
and there's transpositions even
from the italian to the rye lopez the
one thing that i want to say if you do
play the italian or the rye lopez
in this position you can play the move
bishop e3
very common idea also in the rye lopez
why is knight takes c4 impossible can
somebody tell me an
extra credit two reasons why knight
takes e4
loses the game or loses a lot of
material i did insult your parakeets
codex i didn't miss your question the
lolly i will get back to it
codex i sorry i missed your question
initially but i'll get back to it knight
takes e4
very careful we've talked about this
scenario
black can take on e1 with check and then
he takes the bishop so careful one is
this
boom boom folkovich no way for black to
save both pieces and then there's
another fork
well actually okay i'm lying to people
i'm meant to say queen c2 also forks but
black can go queen e8 and defend both
pieces
and then now you're gonna have to go
bishop d5 anyway so the reality is both
of these are
reliant on bishop d5 um let's move on to
the second game
which was which was a very quick one now
morphy against duke of brunswick
is one of the most famous games of all
time i know that um
most of you have seen it before i think
it's one of the most overrated games of
all time
it's also called the opera game why is
it called the opera game because it was
played
during a production of an opera paul
morphy
went to europe to play the strongest
players in the world at that time
because he'd beaten everybody in the
united states he was invited by a
dignitary i think from austria to to
attend an opera
and uh anybody who's been to i mean i
respect opera greatly but
it's got some comfortable seats and
about 10 minutes into production of
norma
which i don't remember who the composer
is but i knew that was the opera
um so now you know more about the opera
game than anybody else
um it was during production of norma uh
and
morphe turned to duke brunswick who
invited him so i'm bored
let's go to the popcorn stand except
it's the 1800s you don't serve popcorn
with opera
let's get some beer okay they got a
glass of beer during the intervention
let's play some chess
that we can all agree on so they sit
down they start playing a chess game
duke brunswick and his friend
uh count isaward a second austrian
dignitary
sits down with paul morphy and they
start bellini okay
and uh they were not very good and
that's part of the reason i think this
is a very overrated game this is how the
game started in this position
count and duke played knight f6 which
allowed morphy to slide his queen to b3
and
fork these two pawns and the game went
on for them i'm not gonna show the game
our opponent play queen e7 which is
probably even worse because uh
it obstructs the development of the
bishop and it allows our knight to get
to d5 with temple now he's going to burn
another tempo to stop her knight's get
from t5 i mean so this is just
a humongous material advantage and
really the most important move of the
game was here
the move queen h3 we got a donut oh
chewy with 50. picture this as a
birthday card from your
game well thank you chewie for the uh
for the 50 bucks the support today has
been incredible
uh as has the viewership and and the
the the community so thank you chewie
for 50 bucks and all of your support
i appreciate it very much thank you
thank you so much
th the right move for black here would
probably be 97 but now the bishop can't
develop
the poor bishop on f8 uh is always
blocked by some pieces and now we can
try to get our bishop to c5
capture that knight and get our queen to
see it notice that he cannot move the
other night because he's always gonna
get checkmated i mean that's what he
tried to do
and he got checkmated so uh you know
this is
this is just a horrendous position and
that's why i don't recommend the
philidor
uh because because it's an opening that
in order to play it properly
you have to really know a lot of theory
you have to you know you really have to
analyze it well and you can get into
this kind of trouble
so this brings me to the final game
and um this is uh the move bishop c4
which
uh here in charlotte we call this the
scholastic variation
and and the reason we call it the
scholastic variation is because
a lot of kids particularly they they
play the italian or they play the
bishops opening
and they they uh assume not illogically
that
this would be a good move against the
sicilian and it's it loses a lot of its
effectiveness
oh loli yes sorry codex my bad i might
totally my bad sorry about that we had a
very
good question from codex about the an
opening called the lolly so
a beef when it gar challenged me i was
talking about this position where
there's a very famous move knight takes
f7 this is the classical way to refute
uh the fried liver and recently it has
been determined
that the move d4 is also very good
okay and uh this is not what people like
to hear because i'm basically saying
you're not supposed to sack the knight
you can just play t4 and explode the
center
uh but i believe according to modern
theory and i'm checking right now in
chess base
now how would i check such a thing and
let's make a quick detour for me to
explain this let's say that i'm a gm
whatever
i have a question which of these opening
lines is better what do you do
here's where i go into chess base and
let me share with you guys a chess-based
board and show you exactly
how i would determine to determine this
and how i would analyze
how would i analyze an opening which i
don't know assuming you have chest space
i know not all of you have chest space
i don't recommend it to everybody but um
i'm going to share the entire
chest-based board with people
and i'm going to just expand this so
that so that you can see the notation
and so that you can see stockfish when i
open
it so just please bear with me for a
moment
okay so
let us just a little bit smaller
and then this a little bit bigger and
let's make this smaller and then this
bigger
and then this bigger okay this is not
going to be the best uh
capture but you get the you get the
general image of it
and i'm gonna make my camera smaller so
you can see okay so this is this is
chess space and there's more things up
on top here which i'm gonna display for
aesthetic appeal
i mean this is what the entirety of the
program basically looks like
uh they basically copied microsoft word
in a certain sense uh and and they did
that deliberately
sorry i'm just trying to expand this to
include everything and it's not easy
this is fine now one of the greatest
features of chess space
is the reference button and the
reference button allows you to see
all of the recorded games that have been
played in a particular position
as you can see uh nike five has been
played
36 well d3 is the main move 36 000 and
it gives you a bunch of statistics about
every move that has been played
percentage and it's always from white's
perspective so white wins 54.4 percent
of the game which is normal for white
uh you can see the best players you can
see frequent players
and you can see all of the moves here so
i mean if you go down the list there's a
lot of crazy i mean somebody played
king e2 probably hikaru uh okay no
montevani played kingy too
that's probably some sort of a a mistake
because this guy's a reputable i am
uh okay so that's a that's good to know
but anyways
we go to the fried lover and to address
codex's question
knight a5 is the main move knight takes
d5 you can see has been played four
thousand times and white scores
overwhelmingly in both knight takes f7
and d4
so i we can see that knight takes f7 is
the main move but this move d4
uh is a recent a recent move we can see
that it's been played a couple times in
2020
it's played a lot in the late 2000s uh
so and white scores overwhelmingly well
which basically tells us that this line
needs to be investigated that's actually
how you find rare lines
if you see that the line has scored so
well that probably means
uh it deserves investigation uh even
though
uh it might be very rare and it might
not have been played by that many good
players
we can also click on elo white to see
the highest rated player who's done
something here we see
a short-plated hubner a lot of gm's
thank you for the 400 bits sriracha
i'm good and now we involve our beast we
involve stock fish
and stock fish will tell us a lot of
what we need to know
about the lime this is stock fish 12
this is the latest version of stock fish
and stockfish has a function called
depth
and depth is essentially how many moves
ahead stockfish sees the higher the
depth
of the more informed the opinion about
the position you get the more reliable
it
normally when i'm analyzing an opening i
want to let stockfish reach depth 35
before i really trust its evaluation
as you can see it's giving an evaluation
at approximately depth 32 of plus minus
which means that white is clearly better
thank you lily
and the evaluation is going down
slightly uh
and uh you can see that white is much
better here but we would go back and see
knight takes f7
and we would let it sit here and we
would analyze and we would basically
just see the evaluation i mean this
isn't rocket science
at least initially the evaluation is not
as overwhelming as we might think
um and and what happens when you're a gm
and you're trying to analyze this is you
essentially look at all of the moves
that have been played by humans
you list them you say he takes d479 main
line bishop e7
and on top of that you always include
stockfish's main move because you assume
that people prepare for this
and then you basically use stockfish to
create a file right if this isn't rocket
science
um this is how i would do it i would
just create a file by analyzing all of
these lines and trying to figure out
white's best continuation and eventually
i'd get a sense of if this line i would
rather play and i would do the same
thing with knight takes f7 which is of
course more fun
uh and and he would do this as well so
this is not the most interesting thing
but to answer your question codex i
think that d4 is considered right now to
be a little bit better
than knight takes f7 it's a little bit
cleaner and it's harder for black to
actually play
and the purpose of d4 is that you open
up the bishop and in this position
you can see the evaluation white is
winning and the reason that white is
winning is because he's got this
incredibly strong knight he's got all
these files i mean the king is just
caught in the crossfire
of this position and now you play knight
takes f7 and this is much stronger in
comparison
because you've got the e-file uh in
comparison to taking immediately when
the e-file is still closed
which makes it a little bit harder to
attack um so
so so hopefully this gives people a
little bit of a sense of how how people
analyze it
at a high level now once you create the
file you memorize it right if you're a
gm and you create a long file
i mean let me show you an example of
what my file looks like okay and i'm
trying to demystify this
to people because i i hate this this
this entire uh school of thought that
the gm's
you know do this abracadabra like magic
i do the same stuff that you guys might
do i just do it maybe at
a slightly deeper level but that doesn't
mean you know i'm doing anything special
so if you just give me a second i'll
find a
non-compromising file that i that i have
made
and um okay so
i i will reveal some of my preparation
here which is okay
which is okay uh this is my file
all right oh i know where i know where
to find some of my files that i can show
you guys if you just please bear with me
for one moment
um and i know people might be excited at
this
but i want to open something that
doesn't feature anything
that anybody else recommended to me
because that would be unfair to that
person
yes i found it here it is there we go
okay so let me show you a file from 2015
and i was already a gm so
it's it's not like this is that old
so let me just replace this
all right okay there we go i need to
make this a little bit smaller so you
can see everything
okay
so this is my file on the
chigorin which is an opening in the rye
lopez
and i'm analyzing this from black's
perspective so trigoran is one of my
main lines
um and uh i this is the official file
that i made
uh from black's perspective in the
trigorin and you can see it's just a
chess-based file it's also
can be transferred into a pgn file this
is the chigorin by the way it's the line
of the rylopa as the black and play
uh and you can see a couple of things
here you can see that uh i'm i'm
inputting a lot of text
and the reason that i input text is that
when i'm reviewing the file
five years later uh i i want to know
why certain moves are played i don't
want to re-go through the process of
determining
why certain moves are made i want all
ready for that to be explained
so that i don't have to constantly
redetermine what the ideas are
you can see the d5 the old main line
okay that's good to know which means
it's probably not going to occur as
often now
blah blah blah and not the most popular
move so you can see
and in these positions i'm making a long
text note
really to explain the ideas so i'm
saying this is my recommendation it
might trigger and file for white almost
everyone takes on d4 automatically
leading to a typical e4 d6 pawn position
which blocks excellently coordinated
pieces
and the better this is written the more
easier it is to read five years later
you don't want to look at a file and for
it to have some sort of crappy text that
you wrote in two seconds you want to put
a lot of effort
into this stuff uh and and one thing
that i would do is if i were to go
through this with modern stockfish
i would see that there are some mistakes
because computers have gotten stronger
and i would update this if i haven't
updated it
but you can see that my main line goes
through move 34.
uh and i know that may seem impressive
but it's not that i want to do this it's
that i have to do this
because this is how deeply people
analyze nowadays
and it ends in equality which is of
course what we want to do if we're
playing black
and and this is just a an example of one
such file
um i'm not a specialist in the opening
so i don't have
as many as i should and i haven't
updated them as diligently as they
should
thank you badour uh when we got a whoa
we got a fifty dollar donation from
this is incredible badur jabava is not
only
in the chat but a 50 donation from grand
master bharat or jabba i was going to
show you my jumbava variation file
um and uh that's a little bit recent so
i didn't want to leak that
but badour with 50 bucks uh and
wishing me happy birthday and honor to
have him in the chat
and to have him watching my stream
really so thank you so much for
a huge privilege to have so many strong
players in
in my chat consistently uh thank you so
much
and nicola with 2 000 bits as well thank
you
i can't even keep up with this okay um
and badur of course recently has started
to stream he's he's awesome
uh fymit thank you for the prime
and uh this is amazing thank you so much
uh everybody
okay so back to the speed run because i
know everybody's excited to continue
i think you get the point this is what
opening analysis looks like i went in a
little bit of a tangent there but
hopefully people find this
you know find this helpful um
yeah definitely zay-z i'd consider it
the reality is
the more you memorize the better uh and
the more you understand the better there
is no
limit or like target that i that i reach
when i'm trying to memorize files i'm
trying to memorize as much as i can
but hopefully this shows you guys why
chess is a full-time occupation
they don't show this in the queen's
gambit okay when beth walks in to play
borgob or whatever
and they did this the same the way in
the old days and they just had files
that they would write down in notebooks
it's the same analysis
i wouldn't be as extensive but it would
was the same process
and this is the non-glamorous part of
chess work that nobody
really appreciates entirely i think and
i don't mean this in an accusatory way
but but the reality is uh this is not a
glamorous process it's very very
cumbersome it's very boring at times
if you think i'm not bored out of my
mind when i'm you know sitting with
stockfish for 10 minutes letting it sit
and think about a sort of boring
position that may never occur
of course it's incredibly boring for me
but it's necessary work if you want to
get better
so just wanted to give people a window
into how this stuff works